welcome to Stanford's advanced security
certification course on mobile security
my name is Neil de swanny and I'll be
teaching this course together with Dan
Bonet and John Mitchell in this course
what we want to do is provide you with
an understanding of privacy and security
trade-offs for the most popular mobile
platforms then we'll delve into privacy
and security threats and how to design
and build secure mobile applications as
well as Android and iOS and how to
address privacy and security threats
specific to those platforms and then
finally how to manage mobile
applications and mobile devices in an
enterprise type of environment so that's
a quick overview of the key things that
we are going to walk through in this
course
you